- It's almost time to go, y'all.
But before we do, I have
one more story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
Last month, an author in
Ohio took to Twitter to vent
about a recent book signing
with a disappointing turnout.
She wrote, "Only two people came
to my author signing yesterday,
so I was pretty bummed about it.
Especially as 37 people
responded, 'going', to the event.
Kind of upset, honestly,
and a little embarrassed."
That author was Chelsea Banning,
and she was promoting her
self-published debut novel,
"Of Crowns And Legends".
I think any artist can relate
to that kind of disappointment at a show.
But what happened next is truly amazing.
It's very cool.
The post went viral, and
authors like Stephen King,
Margaret Atwood, and Neil Gaiman chimed in
with their book signing
horror stories as well.
The best part, "Of Crowns And Legends"
rocketed up the Amazon
charts, not too shabby.
We have Chelsea joining us now.
What's up Chelsea?
(audience clapping)
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly!
How are you?
- I am so good!
I love how this story turned out,
'cause how bad was this signing?
- Oh, it was pretty disheartening
because I was there a few hours,
and only a couple people showed up,
and I was still feeling
sad on the way home
and the next morning, and I
just really wanted to talk
to other writers about it.
So, I went to Twitter to kind
of just vent into the void,
not really thinking anyone's gonna see it.
And then a couple hours
later, it went viral,
and there's all these
amazing authors chiming in
with their own signing horror stories.
Like you said, Neil Gaiman,
Stephen King, Margaret Atwood,
and so many more, and
even other celebrities.
And it was just so heartwarming
and encouraging, and truly a blessing.
- Well, it is important to note
that everyone thinks it happens overnight.
Even with me, I did things
before "American Idol",
and there are disappointing
turnouts, and you think,
"Oh my God, should I keep doing this?"
And it can be very discouraging.
So, it's important to
tell people these stories,
and it's also important for people
like the Stephen King's,
and Margaret Atwood's,
to join in and say, "This
happened to me as well."
It's a very cool thing,
and congratulations on writing
a book in the first place
and sharing your voice with the world.
(audience clapping)
That's an incredible thing
to write a novel.
So, tell us what it's about.
- So, it is a King Arthur re-imagining.
It takes place 20 years
after King Arthur's death,
and it follows the twin
children he and Guinevere
were never supposed to have.
So, they weren't supposed to exist.
And it follows their
adventures, there's magic.
You'll meet new characters,
you'll see old characters
from Arthurian Myth,
like Guinevere, Merlin, and all of them.
It's book one of three.
- Oh, it's a trilogy.
That's cool.
- As you said, it soared
to the Amazon charts
in Arthurian Fantasy,
and now I even have another signing
at the same bookstore later this month.
(audience clapping)
- Ah, that's awesome.
I love these kind of stories.
So, I can't wait to read
it, I'm so proud of you.
I'm liking your post right now, alright.
(bell rings)
- [Chelsea] Oh, thank you so much!
- And that's not all, girl.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to honor fearless
creators, just like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- What?
No way!
- [Kelly] I cannot wait
to read your books.
Congratulations, girl!
(audience clapping)